-I saw you tweeted
that you would have a hard time
living in New York
because of the restaurants.
-I would. I live in Houston.
There's traffic everywhere.
I mean, if I want to go
somewhere out to eat,
it's about 20 or 30 minutes
to get there.
Here, you walk downstairs,
and it's literally pizza, sushi,
ice cream, pizza, sushi.
My girlfriend and I were walking
around and we were like,
"Well, we don't really have
anything going on.
Should we stop for some food?"
And we'll stop in,
and we'll get pizza,
and then we're walking
20 more feet, and she's like,
"I heard of this restaurant.
It's incredible.
We have to go in."
And I'm like,
"Well, we have to go in."
I swear to God
I'd be 450 pounds.
-Yeah.
If you ever end up
on the Giants or the Jets,
people should just know now
to be disappointed.
-Yeah, you should prob--
Just void my contract
or move me to the offensive line
right out of the gate.
-You got -- You were at
the Super Bowl this year.
Obviously, you guys,
the Texans, had a great season.
It didn't end the way
you wanted it to.
You went to
the Super Bowl because,
as a previous winner
of Man of the Year,
you presented it
to this year's winner.
Was there any joy
in being at the Super Bowl
without your team there?
-No.
-Yeah. Huge bummer?
-Yeah.
-Could you watch the game?
-No.
-Yeah, okay.
-[ Laughs ] I handed out the
award right before the game.
They did the opening kickoff,
and I was on a jet
30 minutes later.
I couldn't do it.
I can't do it. It's tough.
-Do you watch -- When the season
ends, do you watch at all?
-I mean, I'll watch -- Obviously
I check out the highlights.
I want to see what happened
in the game and everything.
But it's tough, man.
I mean, you work so hard,
and you put in so much work,
and you put in so much time,
and you want to be in that game.
It's hard. It's like --
-I feel that way as a fan.
Like, when my team is out,
as a Steelers fan,
I don't want to watch
anything anymore.
And I feel like I don't --
I mean, obviously
I don't know, but I feel like
you work harder at it than I do.
[ Laughter ]
-That's questionable.
It's possible. It's possible.
I'll yell at my brother for you.
-Thank you.
Well, I do want to say,
you know,
I'm obviously
a huge fan of yours.
I'm a slightly bigger fan
of your brother TJ
because he plays on the
Pittsburgh Steelers,
the team I love,
and your other brother Derek
plays for the Chargers.
-That is correct.
-You guys all went to Wisconsin.
-We did.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We got some Wisconsin
in the house.
And your mother...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He's a Northwestern guy.
-Yeah, I went to Northwestern.
Any Cats here? No? All right.
Well, there you go.
-They're all working down...
-Yeah, exactly.
The financial district.
So, your mom -- Somebody
sent this to her, right?
She got a jersey sent to her --
-Yes, my mom got a jersey.
-Very unique that she has
three children in the NFL.
-She does, and we've played
each other a couple times.
I was hurt when I got to play
both of them,
but they played each other.
So, obviously,
people are always asking,
"What's your mom going to wear?
What's your mom going to wear?"
She can't just wear my jersey,
which she wants to.
So this is what
somebody sent her.
-Very, very unique jersey
that covers all three logos.
And I just realized now
the Watt and the "W"
is the Wisconsin "W."
So that is really --
Somebody put the time in.
-They did. And each letter --
So, that's from the Texans
jersey, that's from --
I mean, somebody went through
a lot of time
for somebody else's family.
-Very nice.
-I appreciate that.
Thank you to whoever sent that.